¿Y por qué los kanaka maoli,
los indígenas hawaianos,
son propensos a contraer la lepra o la "mai pake"?
Las razones que nos hacen únicos como hawaianos despertaron mi curiosidad
es decir, nuestra composición genética.
Pero solo en la escuela secundaria, a través del Proyecto Genoma Humano,
comprendí que no era el único que trataba de encontrar conexiones
entre nuestra herencia genética única y la salud, el bienestar y la enfermedad.
Deben saber que este proyecto de USD 2700 millones
prometía una nueva era de la medicina predictiva y preventiva
basada en nuestra composición genética única.
Así que para mí siempre fue obvio
que para lograr este sueño,
debemos secuenciar un grupo diverso de personas
para obtener el espectro completo de la variación genética humana
a escala mundial.
Es por eso que incluso 10 años después,
me sigue sorprendiendo
que un 96 % de los estudios sobre el genoma
que asocian variaciones genéticas comunes a patologías específicas
se ha centrado exclusivamente en individuos de ascendencia europea.
No se necesita un doctorado
para darse cuenta de que eso deja solo un 4 % para el resto de la diversidad.
Al llevar a cabo mi propia investigación descubrí que menos de un 1 % del total
se han centrado en las comunidades indígenas como la mía.
Lo que plantea la pregunta:
¿a quién se dirige en realidad el Proyecto del Genoma Humano?
Al igual que nuestros ojos y pelo son de diferentes colores,
también la manera de metabolizar los medicamentos
debido a la variación genómica.
Entonces, ¿cuántos de Uds. se sorprenderían al saber
que un 95 % de los ensayos clínicos
se han realizado exclusivamente en individuos de ascendencia europea?
Esta tendencia y esta falta de compromiso sistemática
con las poblaciones indígenas
tanto en los ensayos clínicos como en los estudios del genoma humano
es en parte el resultado de un pasado mutuo de desconfianza.
Por ejemplo, en 1989, investigadores de la Universidad Estatal de Arizona
recolectaron muestras de sangre de la tribu havasupai de Arizona,
prometiendo disminuir la tasa de diabetes de tipo 2
que afectaba a la comunidad,
con la única intención de usar esas mismas muestras
sin el consentimiento de los havasupai
para estudiar la incidencia de la esquizofrenia, la endogamia,
y cuestionar la historia de los orígenes de los havasupai.
Cuando los havasupai lo descubrieron,
ganaron una demanda por USD 700 000,
y se prohibió a la universidad realizar investigaciones en la reserva.
Esto culminó en una especie de efecto dominó
entre las tribus locales del suroeste
-- incluyendo a la Nación Navajo, una de las mayores tribus en el país --
y la declaración de una moratoria sobre la investigación genética.
A pesar de esta historia de desconfianza,
todavía creo que los indígenas pueden beneficiarse de la investigación genética.
Y si no hacemos algo pronto,
aumentará la brecha de las disparidades en la salud.
Hawái, por ejemplo, tiene una mayor esperanza de vida
que el promedio de cualquier otro estado en EE.UU.,
pero, sin embargo, los hawaianos nativos, como yo,
mueren una década antes que nuestros paisanos no nativos,
porque tenemos las tasas más altas de diabetes tipo 2,
sufrimos de obesidad,
y de las causas de muerte número uno y dos en EE.UU.:
las enfermedades cardiovasculares y el cáncer.
Así que ¿cómo nos aseguramos de que las poblaciones
que más necesitan la secuenciación genómica
no son las últimas en beneficiarse?
En mi opinión, hay que hacer la investigación genética más nativa,
Indigenizar la tecnología de la secuenciación del genoma.
Tradicionalmente, los genomas son secuenciados en el laboratorio.
Esta es una imagen de un secuenciador estándar de genes vectoriales.
Es enorme.
Es del tamaño de un refrigerador.
Esto plantea un problema importante.
Pero, ¿y si pudieran secuenciar genomas sobre la marcha en tiempo real?
¿Qué pasaría si pudieran meter un secuenciador de genoma en el bolsillo?
Este secuenciador está basado en nanoporos
es 10 000 veces más pequeño que el secuenciador de genoma tradicional.
No tiene sus limitaciones físicas
y no está conectado a un banco de laboratorio con cables extraños,
grandes cubas de productos químicos o monitores informáticos.
Nos permite popularizar el desarrollo de la tecnología de secuenciación
de manera inmersiva y colaborativa,
activando y potenciando las comunidades indígenas
como ciudadanos-científicos.
100 años más tarde, en Kalaupapa, disponemos de la tecnología
para secuenciar la bacteria de la lepra en tiempo real,
mediante secuenciadores del genoma portátiles,
acceso remoto a Internet
y computación en la nube.
Pero solo si eso es lo que quiere el pueblo hawaiano.
En nuestro espacio,
en nuestros términos.
IndiGenomics trata de la ciencia para el pueblo por el pueblo.
El recurso inicial es consultar a las tribus
y estará enfocado a educar a las comunidades indígenas
sobre el uso potencial y el mal uso de la información genética.
Por último, queremos crear nuestro propio instituto de investigación IndiGenomics
para llevar a cabo nuestros propios experimentos
y educar a la próxima generación de científicos indígenas.
En conclusión, las poblaciones indígenas
deben ser parte y no sujetos de la investigación genética.
Y para los no nativos,
al igual que lo hizo el padre Damián,
la comunidad científica necesita sumergirse en la cultura indígena
o morir en el intento.
(Hawaiano) Mahalo (Gracias).
(Aplausos)